i'll never forget these guys paid twelve
thousand dollars each to sit in that
chair
oh bruh twelve thousand dollars
i got very upset watching the video
we're about to watch
together actually angry i might start
just shouting it's a pitch
it's a pitch this is arguably the worst
advice i've ever
seen given to young entrepreneurs
anybody thinking about their finances
and that's saying a lot because i've
seen and shown
a lot of trash advice
on this channel and it was given
actually by grant cardone
of all people someone who i've been on
the fence for
for a while i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i've been on the fence about it but
i'm gonna just say it here grant cardone
fake guru dude
anyway this is his video undercover
billionaire talks about billionaires
the thumbnail says everyone can become a
billionaire
now let that soak in for a second but
let me tell you my realization before we
get into anything else
there's a breed of fake entrepreneurs on
the internet much like there's a breed
of
fake fighting the wwe you may know it as
now we've all seen wwe before and sure
it's entertaining
but you'd never go to this guy to learn
how to fight
right hopefully but this brand of
entrepreneurs online are saying that
they're basically they're teaching real
entrepreneurship
with these videos and the tough thing to
sort out is that
much like you know some of these these
wwe guys
they might be actually legitimately
jacked like right like they're actually
ripped
but the thing they're actually doing is
just entertainment is not real
in the same way you can have people like
grant cardone who actually are rich
people
but in actual fact the advice they're
giving is fake this is not how you
become
rich and they're doing it as a sort of
multimedia entertainment experience
and it makes me so upset because unlike
the wwe which is mostly a harmless show
there's real problems with telling
entrepreneurs that this is how you
become rich right because you're at risk
of people actually
believing you you're at risk of people
taking you up on your offer so let's
listen to this together with that
preamble out of the way
okay there's 11 000 people that are
interested in changing
their financial condition there's so
much money on this planet folks you have
to keep remembering
surround yourself with people that are
telling you the truth
okay give first lesson surround yourself
with people telling the truth what's the
truth grant
that everybody on this stream could be a
billionaire
okay first red flag how many
billionaires are there in the entire
world
according to forbes uh 2095.
now on green card on stream there's 11
so already he's wrong but fine
i guess he's just trying to be
inspirational whatever maybe he means it
like
you can but most people won't right
let's listen on i don't know if you have
the right mindset
you probably don't have the right
customers yet it sounds like a sarah
mclaughlin commercial honestly like give
a puppy a dollar
elon musk was not a baller
his whole life you're the asset
you are the one that is going to climb
the wealth mountain
okay sorry uh to come back here uh you
know
real entrepreneurs they talk about
products
they talk about market conditions grant
cardone
just said the words and i kid you not
you are the one that is going to climb
the wealth mountain now try to explain
to me
how that's not this this sounds like
something they'd say in the wwe
that's not real they're doing it for a
show for your personal entertainment
if they told you that that'd be fine but
again let's talk he goes yeah elon musk
wasn't always a baller
but wasn't he though i mean he dual
majored in economics and physics
was going to go get his phd but then
dropped out
from stanford in order to go start zip
to then he did paypal
he pretty quickly was a baller this idea
that these guys were losers but then
they heard some famous seminar speaker
and they bootstrapped themselves up to
go be the
the billionaires they are today it's
fake it it's not really how the world
works
and the problem is is not just oh you're
kind of giving dumb advice that's not
the problem that's not what i have a
problem with there's a lot of people
giving dumb advice that we never talk
about
because they don't charge a dollar but
grant cardone is different now listen
who here has made a decision to get to
the top of the pinnacle
again what is that who has made the
decision to get to the top of the
pinnacle what does that have to do with
success
here's the deal about the decision folks
you need to make the decision
and then keep remaking the decision
you got bill gates warren buffett jeff i
can't with this music
he really is though he he's like one of
these he's like a motivational speaker
he's not even giving entrepreneurship
advice
how are you gonna say oh everyone can be
a billionaire and you give the most
milk toast like hoo-rah everybody can do
it speech this is pathetic
you got bill gates warren buffett jeff
bezos jay-z and elon musk
they all know each other they've all
touched each other they all hang with
each other
no they don't dude what was that list
bill gates warren buffett jeff bezos
jay-z and elon musk do not hang out
newsflash yeah they they run in the same
billionaire so but it's not like hey i'm
going to jay-z's out bill gates just
drops by jay-z's house
they do that for press it's like it's
like believing that grant cardone
loves and goes and hangs out with uh
jordan belfort
and tai lopez all the time no they don't
hang out they just do their own thing
and this is going to get worse in a
second here this is what really disgusts
me here watch this collaborate with
power
and then you want to write this down pay
to play
pay to play interesting now we're
getting somewhere because remember
who do you think he's telling you to pay
to play pay what does he mean by that
please elaborate grant i had been told
this
most of my life i did not trust it i was
skeptical
then i saw how much money it could make
me the
easiest way to collaborate with power
is to buy a seat at the table
where can we buy a seat from grant
please help us
these guys over here i don't know if you
guys could pan over here can they see
these guys
look at these guys look at these guys
these guys are spending three days with
me
this might as well be an idiot panel i
mean i'm sorry to you if you spent three
days with grant
why why would you do that i'll never
forget
these guys pay 12 000 each to sit in
that chair
oh bruh 12 000
and he's going yeah pay to play this
terrible advice
these guys they're playing a game to get
your money to extract
wealth from you and it's all the
narrative is
you've got to pay for a mentor and then
surprise surprise
they're the mentor that wants to help
you out right this is not how
entrepreneurs like elon musk got started
do you think elon musk paid someone 12
to mentor him at some business three-day
seminar no
i look over there i'm like man they're
crazy yeah
three days i gotta look at their ugly
faces
okay the reality is i don't know if
they're crazy enough
i know this to get to the top of the no
they're they're doing what you told them
to do
you said in one of your other speeches
oh pay to play or something to that
extent
then they unfortunately listen to you
spit twelve thousand dollars they could
have used for their business and what
are they getting out of it another sales
pitch
from grant cardone guys grant cardone is
a fake guru like again
i was on the fence about him for a while
you guys know that if you follow my
channel because you know what
he is a good salesman that's true but at
the end of the day what is
what is the advice he's giving it's just
all of this
this is the grant cardone show but for
entrepreneurs
you're gonna have to do some crazy
to stay where you are you will have to
do some crazy
are you guys following this logic it's
the most transparent cash crap
i've ever seen from one of these guys
hey you want to be a billionaire you can
be so he tells you the dream
don't be a loser tells you the dream you
need to collaborate with power
but of course he knows you don't have
anyone powerful to collaborate with so
the easiest way to clap it with power
now he's providing you the solution
is to pay to play coincidentally look at
these suckers paid 12 000
over here lined right up and then he
goes yeah they're crazy but are they
crazy
enough do you guys see how manipulative
this is
listen to me to get to the top
you will have to do something crazy stay
where you are what could it be
you will be forced to do something crazy
you'll see what i'm mad i got
furious watching this oh look at that he
goes you're gonna have to do something
crazy
and then he goes reserve your seat now
10x growthcon
it's a pitch it's a pitch his whole
thing is
undercover billionaire talks about
billionaires guys it's just a pitch to
make him richer does anybody get this
does anybody understand does anybody see
what i'm seeing listen
i don't care if you watch grant cardone
god bless you go go have some fun
it's entertainment and occasionally
man's got a point
you know you can only say so many
aphorisms like
uh you know early to bed early to rise
before you're kind of
right i mean a little bit right but this
is you're not gonna watch this and
become an entrepreneur
please what i like about the wwe is
they're open about it now they go yeah
it's entertaining they call it sports
entertainment because it's not real
fighting right if grant cardone were to
come out tomorrow and go hey
guys duh you're not going to become a
billionaire
by doing a three-day wealth summit or
whatever
10x growth con 10x 10x if you did that
i'd have no problem i wouldn't be here
shouting to the void
right but instead you're gonna do it to
me grant you're gonna go oh i believe in
you
i believe anyone could be a billionaire
no you know they can't be a billionaire
grant
you're lying you know it's actually
factually impossible actually
11 000 people aren't gonna become a
billionaire really pisses me off
uh that this kind of crap is going
around and then let's
it's just it's like people don't know
right because you look at the sentiment
under this video and i hate to do this
but look at this
1700 people like this post and then all
the comments are positive
everyone can become a billionaire no
they can't if you have the right group
of friends no they can't
great motivation nope great mindset nope
that's not how you become a billionaire
the reason jeff bezos is a billionaire
is not because of his
mindset the reason jeff bezos is a
billionaire is he was a smart guy
with a lot of things going for him he
went to top-tier schools then he took a
gigantic risk and it paid off
it blows my mind how these people have
hoodwinked so many people
into into thinking they and jeff bezos
they're like the same people
and i know you guys aren't going to want
to hear this right i know you're not
going to want to hear this you're going
to be like grant cardone also has real
estate yes
okay yeah sure but at the end of the day
what's he teaching
what's he's teaching this so that's uh
i'm gonna call him what he is right
if you go you become part of the wwe
you're fake fighting that's what you do
if you sell 10x growthcon tickets by
saying
do something crazy and pay me 12 000
this is what you're doing
anyway that's it for today i hope you i
hope you enjoyed so i got a little
heated during this one
i can't stand these people i mean it's
just like it's it's enough is enough
if they weren't taking money from broke
people look how many people do you think
in that room
spent money they could have been
spending on their business to listen to
this guy all right guys i think i made
my point like didn't dive
uh thanks for watching see you
ain't what it later nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee